one giorno matteo ghisalberti merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
le mouvement 5 étoiles auquel
appartiennent un tiers des
parlementaires italiens va donc
rejoindre le futur gouvernement pour
tandis que le parti de luigi di maio est
un parti anti système
mais mario draghi lui l'ex directeur de
la banque centrale européenne tout sauf
un anti système donc comment un tel
mariage peut se passer
en effet on peut penser qu'il s'agit
d'un mariage contre nature parce que les
deux camps étaient opposés jusqu'il ya
quelques heures on peut dire mais le
problème c'est que d'un côté il y a les
parlementaires du mouvement 5 étoiles
qui craignent d'être de disparaître aux
prochaines élections parce qu'ils ont
déçu d'abord leur base électorale et
puis et aussi les italiens parce qu'ils
ont fait est fait et par mesure de gérer
cette crise sanitaire mais aussi les
autres défis économiques et que l'italie
avait déjà avant la crise sanitaire les
coronavirus et puis
il ne veut pas oublier que le mouvement
5 étoiles est à l'origine aussi da de la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
donc les parlementaires de ce parti créé
n'est vraiment des nouvelles élections
et donc ils sont prêtes à avaler tous
les couleurs je voudrais dire et mais il
faut dire aussi que ce vote sur leur
plate forme de décisions internes a
vraiment marqué une facture dans les
deux hommes entendent et des sommes dues
du mouvement parce que il y allume des
représentants historiques de la première
heure qui s'appelle la halle et ça no 10
baptistes a dit qu'il l'ait claque la
porte et qui donc il a il amènera avec
lui est vraisembablement une bonne
partie de la base et peut être aussi
quelques députés sénateurs donc cela
pourrait affaiblir un petit peu la
majorité parlementaire pour le
gouvernement de mario draghi
en tout cas pour le gouvernement de
mario draghi il va y avoir des priorités
1 pour cette coalition très hétéroclite
donc la crise sanitaire c'est le
chantier numéro un
sans doute mais il ya aussi la nécessité
disons de données chez eux aux poudres
économique dans les sens que l'on attend
forcément l'arrivée du recovery tool and
robin doak le plein des aides de l'union
européenne mais
la première mouture des ombres de ceux
des plans pour relancer le pays
présenté par le gouvernement de compter
le comté 2 n'était pas très clair donc
mario draghi aura sans doute cette
grande tâche qui mise à réduire la
bureaucratie augmenté par contre de
développer la la justice du point de vue
de la sûreté du droit donc accéléré
faire mieux fonctionner la justice mais
aussi la santé naturellement on a vu
avec le coronavirus et il faudra aussi
arrêter avec les atermoiements sur les
grands dossiers des infrastructures
parce que le mouvement cinq étoiles a
été aussi l'un des freins pour les
réalisations des grands oeuvre notamment
la ligne à haute vitesse lyon turin mais
aussi d'autres infrastructures qui
concernait d'autres régions et donc je
pense que monsieur draghi sifflera la
fin de la récréation un prix mais aussi
sur ces sujets parce que l'italie
d'ailleurs a besoin de ces
infrastructures et a besoin de aussi des
plus de compétitivité pour être hop avec
les prochains défis et qui nous attend
mario draghi pourrait annoncer son
nouveau gouvernement aujourd'hui ou dans
les prochains jours à quoi est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre en termes de répartition
des portefeuilles
c'est très c'est très difficile de le
dire mais c'est long les dernières
dépêches que j'ai pu consulter ces
matins on annonce des ministres
techniques pas mal des ministres
techniques comme on les appelle en
italie
c'est à dire des personnalités
indépendantes et spécialisés dans leur
domaine notamment on pourrait voir des
représentants ainsi un représentant de
la banque d'italie qui est donc être
connais très bien
mario draghi dans les ministères
économiques mais on pourrait aussi voir
des figures politiques et notamment en
pressenti
la confirmation de luigi di maio à au
ministère des affaires étrangères mais
on pourrait voir aussi arriver des
représentants de la ligue
il faut dire que matteo salvini
apparemment ne voudrais pas rentrer dans
le gouvernement pour ne pas lui donner
une connotation trop politique
mais voilà ça c'est les dernières
informations c'est aussi qu est une des
personnalités qui était pressenti pour
devenir d'ailleurs le premier ministre
l'ancienne présidente de la cour
constitutionnelle
martha carte à bria va devenir
probablement le ministre de la justice
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer
cette instabilité politique chronique en
italie on le rappelle un plus de 70
gouvernement depuis 1946 et du coup
comment réagissent les figures de
l'opposition vous avez évoqué matteo
salvini à l'instant et aussi matteo
renzi celle d'août il faut se rappeler
qu'à l'italie est une démocratie
parlementaire donc quand on passe à
travers un parlement on a une expression
de plus élargie de la base électorale
il faut dire aussi que les italiens ont
toujours
ont presque toujours choisi d'avoir une
représentation basé sur le système
proportionnel qui a sans doute le défaut
de morceler le nombre de partis dans les
deux chambres mais en même temps il est
dit dans la plupart des cas des
explosions
les colères populaires comme celle qu'on
a pu voir aussi dans d'autres pays
donc le fait qu'ils aient qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de gouvernements
c'était malheureusement le résultat des
comment dire du marchandage des partis
politiques
tout au long de ses 50 ans soixante dix
ans après la deuxième guerre mondiale
mais ça a donné aussi une façon très
pratique et pour exprimer la démocratie
en italie parce qu'il ne faut pas
oublier que cannes italie on a eu une
dictature celle de mussolini et donc on
a choisi quand on a fait entrer en
vigueur la nouvelle la constitution en
1948 de le rédiger
la collégialité plutôt que la
concentration de pouvoirs sur une seule
figure et institutionnels merci matteo
ghisalberti d'avoir répondu à une
question grazie mille et je rappelle que
vous êtes genlis franco-italien est le
rédacteur en chef du site d'informations
pour magna